think it's okay to bomb a
hospital they just they can cry I can
cry we all can cry if we're not crying
something is wrong I mean they held I
think I have no problem saying in
essence it was a modern-day Nazi rally
last week I mean it was absolutely
insane no one is making the distinction
there was not one person there who made
the distinction between the Palestinian
flag and the actions of Hamas the the
the entire world goes insane I mean
congrations everywhere things on fire
giant protest and rash TB out there oh
my God the babies oh my God the babies
when it comes out as it already has that
it was a Palestinian Islamic Jihad
rocket that hit a that that even if it
had hit a hospital and killed 500 people
her move would then not be why is
Palestinian Islamic Jihad firing rockets
that kill civilians in Gaza it would be
this never happened it would be this is
not important anymore I'm not going to
talk about this right it exits the front
page the minute right that it can't be
blamed on the Jews it exits the front
page that's how you know all this is
crocodile teers